[Music]
Jonathan what have you done
[Music]
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
tell me what you want person I can't
help you to reach the unreachable
you expected to meet you downwards a 40
million dollar bounty on his head
never would the city wants a piece of it
I say the author about evil dark - five
seconds
Charlie comunicados in effect in three
two
and away we go
[Music]
[Music]
Sophia we're not going in like the old
days just the conversation nothing's
ever just a conversation with you John
[Music]
[Music]
25 years ago you played a concert in
front of the entire world
one month ago you played in Barstow
California for 40 people most of them
were there for $2 taco night billing Ted
what have you got to say for yourselves
be excellent to each other and party on
dudes you were supposed to unite the
world and pave reality as we know it
we've spent our whole life trying to
write the song level reunite the world
why can't we just go to the future when
we have written it whoa take it from
ourselves isn't that stealing how is
that stealing if we're stealing it from
ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
no way how'd you like our song it's a
little on the dark side but you know
that's cool hey Dad
morning morning it'll be like it never
happened what's going on
William something's not right with me
tell me the truth there was a crash
you and the kids tied initiate I brought
you back there is a reason human cloning
is banned death
we stole millions of dollars worth of
iodine equipment I hope you're ready to
go to jail
those three subjects are our property
I didn't define everything natural water
is just a loose - again
how could you do this because I love you
[Music]
have you ever had a dream view that you
were so sure was real what if you were
unable to wake from that dream how would
you know the difference between the
dream world and the real this kid you
wanted to know what the matrix is near
it is the world that has been pulled
over your eyes to blind you from the
truth what truth you've been living in
the dream world neo
as long as the matrix exists the human
race will never be free
free your mind
that's a nice dress thank you I like
your jacket
Thanks flights on time it is great I'm
sorry what was that what you just took a
step forward there again yeah you did
you know you did and if what's funny is
there's no way you can board first
because the only way the board versus is
to be a special need do you have a
special need yes I need to be over there
I'm going to the destination wedding
myself tell me experiment so we're just
the people you don't know how to stick
you might as well just stick us together
I don't want to be a person you don't
know where to stick definition buddy was
presumptuous they're in a fool's
paradise she believed there's someone
for everyone close I believe that
there's nobody for anyone
I understand how even after Keith did
what he did to you can possibly still be
mooning over because you're a monkey who
doesn't understand the human condition
having met you I understand why it's a
condition
you know I'm not wearing anything in my
pajamas why would you they're so
annoying
[Music]
what is that I think it's a mountain
lion could appear Jack what difference
does it make mm-hmm cougar maybe Jesus
Christ
how do you not install a pathway the
heels won't make it can't carry me
please
[Music]
what cold sure Bobby's know
mr. Casas Dean I'd like to ask you a few
questions I know the circles you travel
in be called exorcisms easy they hammer
its dragon's breath I thought she
couldn't get it didn't know a guy who
knows a girl I thought that you can at
least point me in the right direction
yeah please
what if I told you that God in the devil
made of weight that the souls of all men
come no direct contact with humans that
would be the world just influence see
would with demons stain him and rose in
heaven they call it the balance I need
to see what you see you do this there's
no time back you see them
they see you understand
[Music]
[Music]
nice try Thanks how much for the car
she's not for sale
[Music]
Jonathan you got out once it's personal
it's not what you did son it's hurry it
dated to the nobody but nobody is
jumping
[Music]
come on so I'm here three man with a pet
show
hey Josh as I let myself in
people keep asking if I'm back yeah I'm
thinking I'm back
I'm not afraid of John wick you should
be
working again now I just sorted berry
huh
do you want to be friends too Gary
[Music]
summer the search begins friends don't
let friends do a vigorous quest
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me sage good mood I made out
of sage and I am a sage so it works out
pretty well
I'm Patrick my name means toaster in
Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most
amazing places look wouldn't worry about
us losing
[Music]
[Applause]
sponge on the run oh I love your sense
of irony Patrick thank you I love my
sense of irony - wait why am i alive you
are a toy you belong to Bonnie these are
your friends woody I have a question um
well actually not just one I have all
the questions who wants to go on a road
trip you need help with that no no I got
it
oh this is a little strange but we all
have to make sure nothing happens to
four key but we gotta get Roger that
[Music]
change of plans
Jesse hey let's go save a spork do I
need to be worried
my guys are veteran so hang in there
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah posing yeah hold on one more oh
yeah I've known that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside
there's so much body needs for you Oh
Sheriff would you always come into the
rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
Duke for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
four keys being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]